no rest for the European Union this
summer with the crisis in Turkey the
British decision to leave the European
Union and terrorism my guests here in
Brussels is Miroslav lie check foreign
minister of slovakia which currently
holds the EU presidency is he up to the
job
Miroslav lie check welcome to complex on
thank you for an invitation let's begin
with turkey 9000 police fired three
thousand judges suspended at least six
thousand military personnel detained and
the EU warns not to abandon the rule of
law it must be apparent to you that the
rule of law has been abandoned in Turkey
a long time ago hasn't it
I wouldn't say that but now we are in
the different situation after the coup
we always expressed our strong support
for the President and for the
constitutional order at the same time
after the coup what's happening it's
probably too much and too quickly and
therefore we have expressed our concerns
and now is the time to say that there
are certain limits it should not be
crossed
yes but the limits will cross the long
term go on human rights on treatment of
Kurds on the crackdown on civil society
it's time to look for other solutions
for your migrant problem than to farm it
out to a country that has very little
regard for human rights I think it would
be a very big mistake if we consider
that because of migrants and because we
need Turkey on migration issue that we
are going to give any discounts on human
rights or on the rule of law we already
have massive crackdown on civil society
yes and you express concern so every
time something goes wrong and every time
the situation deteriorates you express
concern but you don't do anything no I
disagree we expressed concern now the
most lately but European Union has said
many times that we look into the
situation with human rights with the
situation of the Kurds with respect of
law with a respect for European
standards and norms and this is one of
the obstacles why turkey is not
progressing on its European agenda and
the reports that Turkey has been
actually shooting migrants on the border
from Syria and that doesn't give you
pause for thought or concern either that
perhaps this is not the right country to
be dealing with on this level Turkey is
where it is and Turkey will stay where
it is and Turkey is an important
three and we need this is about shooting
refugees don't mind where it is this is
about shooting refugees actually finish
my my thought and i'm namely we need to
be engaged in a dialogue be the critical
dialogue but how else you want to change
the situation we need to communicate and
we do have a dialogue and we some at
moments critical but that's the best way
how to how to talk about things and how
to eventually improve the thing but it's
a rapidly disintegrating relationship
isn't it no I wouldn't say so
it's the relationship is strong look we
are also allies in NATO and Turkey's an
extremely important country in NATO
turkey wants to join the European Union
but European Union of course is based on
rules and on values and you have to to
meet these these values and to respect
these rules that's going on you just
give them a little slap on the wrist and
say okay it's a good relationship just
continue the way businesses but
engagement is always better than this
again this engagement if we don't talk
somebody else would let's look at the
the migrant crisis oh yes of course
demands unity and trust I think you've
said this you've made this you reject
the commission quotas for Slovakia
you're taking the EU to court to fight
the cultures you're bringing disunity
and distrust into the European Union why
not at all you think this is funny it's
not funny but I mean the way you
describe it is it's funny because this
is the truth of it is no no no because
European Union is based on the
philosophy United in diversity right so
we invited your disunited we are not
this united we have our views we have
our opinion if water is dropping from
the ceiling in your house what are you
going to do are you going to distribute
the water into other rooms or you are
going to fix the ceiling you know the
rules there was a vote a majority vote
by interior ministers of the EU they
decided on the quotas you didn't get
what you wanted but being part of the
club you have to accept it don't you one
of the strongest thing about the
European idea which I am very proud of
is
fact that we don't twist arms but we
talk we listen to each other and in the
end we arrive at a solution that
everyone can lift it this was not the
case this time we were objected to the
arms twisting there was an idea and all
stressing it was a vote once again you
knew the rules now let you knew the
rules but first of all you come up with
the idea and if someone objects the idea
normally European Way is that you try to
accommodate you ask that country why you
don't think it's a bad idea and you try
to accommodate and this time European
Union abandoned this philosophy so look
you took a vote these are the rules you
accepted the rules when you join the
club you can't just pick the ones you
like and discuss what I'm trying to say
is that the migration issue is an
extremely complex issue which has a
political dimension economic damage
social damage and cultural damage
security damage and you are going to
deal with this issue through
administrative ways is it an
administrative problem obviously there
is no majority decided in the year they
decided it was you want unity do you
think you have the presidency of the EU
at the moment you're supposed to retain
unity you encourage unity to remote
unity does it mean you must have no
opinion on your own you can have an
opinion we do know you know but you obey
the rules no we'd always obeyed the
rules
we always advance why are you taking the
EU to court obey the rules are we the
first ones I'm asking you about you look
now right no right now we have the
presidency and as a presidency we are an
honest broker we are not promoting our
agenda we are not hiding from any agenda
we are promoting all the issues that are
on the table so this is how what the
presidency showed to the fact that we
turned to the court is not an
unprecedented thing it's a normal
instrument of European politics let's
have the court decide and we I see
absolutely no contradiction or
absolutely no problem in that Minister
what you're also doing is discriminating
on the grounds of religion because in
direct violation of the commitments that
you have signed up to it March
your Prime Minister robert fico told an
election rally in bratislava i will
never allow a single Muslim immigrant
under a quota system this is straight
discrimination one of the grounds of no
one was ever rejected asylum in Slovakia
based on religion so what so what was he
just counted you're part of his
government
this is collective response I own that
I'm telling you the facts no one no one
was ever rejected the year before he
said we are monitoring every Muslim in
Slovakia this is religious
discrimination you should see these
statements in the context of electoral
campaign what what context could make
that sound better than it already does
that people felt I would say under
pressure from an and from the European
institutions that were pushing them into
something which was new to them they
were not used to it so they reacted with
fear and you have to understand the fact
that there are countries who have been
open to other cultures for centuries and
there are countries for whom this is a
new experience and you cannot this
cannot be ordered overnight it has to be
a process you have to explain to people
they have to get used to it and we have
an excellent model in Slovakia where we
are hosting the migrants who have
applied for asylum in Austria but they
stay in Slovakia we take care of them
and this is many well more than 1,200 so
this is a reality this helps our people
to get used to them and this this is how
we should proceed article 21 of the
Charter of Fundamental Rights of the EU
reads any discrimination on any grounds
such as sex race color ethnic or social
origin genetic features language
religion or belief shall be prohibited
you signed up to the show me one example
tell me one name who was ever rejected
who was discriminated as well I'm
looking at the comments that have been
made which are inciting discrimination
your Prime Minister who said he would
never make a voluntary decision that
would lead to the formation of a unified
Muslim community in Slovakia Islam has
no place in Slovakia
that is not discrimination on the
grounds of religion tell me what is
loves go go go and has my Prime Minister
about the context I am Telling You serve
him I'm telling the facts and you serve
Him and proudly saying you that there
has never been a discrimination on the
basis of religion or on any other basis
in my country full stop these statements
these policies which you may or may not
sign up to give the green light to
people to join far-right anti-immigrant
more anti-muslim parties we are running
at 8% in your country and allowing
people like the head of the Nazi Party
Marian cut labor to call gypsies
parasites to be indicted and have the
court throw it out throw out the
prosecution this is a very wild
construction it's not wild construction
which I love it is not true how long
have you lived in slower which is how
much you know that country so you cannot
judge the country you don't know you
don't know how the people think I mean
you should know the environment you
should make that okay because I know the
country with I've lived in it or not
make it okay of course you'll have
racist language like that calling
gypsies parasites and then to be
prosecuted Marion Court labor but he's a
Nazi and I said clearly on the record
that he's a Nazi so well he's a Nazi but
he can get away with saying that because
the court threw out the prosecution
against him I don't know what to say now
so then I'm responsible for the decision
of an independent court in Slovakia is
it an independent court if it throws out
that kind of that kind of indictment is
it an independent court well I do
believe that our judiciary is
independent why do muslims frighten you
in slovakia so much why are you so
intolerant because our people are have
not been exposed to them and they are if
they're they are frightened it's a new
phenomenon for them so they need to
write about what is your own culture in
your own identity so fragile that you
think we were possibly influenced part
of the project muslims is going to spoil
your country 100 muslims means nothing
in belgium or in london but
it does mean something in Slovakia
because there is what does it mean mr.
white you know the threat no if you
don't know something you know you then
you can you can be threatened because
you don't know you know people are
afraid of what they know don't know and
if something is being enforced upon them
instead of being explained why they
should accept then you can create this
so it's all it always takes to two parts
two sides you must not be pushing
because then you you'll create a contra
pushing this is exactly what I'm saying
this is not the European way to be
afraid when their prime minister tells
them he has to protect the vak you are
against the people who are coming he
said that I have to protect you are
exaggerating and once again everyone who
has ever asked for asylum in Slovakia
was granted asylum if if that person met
the conditions and there was never any
discrimination let's respect the facts
let's respect the statements as well the
statements are true
I know statements have been made the
facts are there on the record there on
you know so you disavow the statements
that your Prime Minister has made
because I know that you can't have it
both ways mr. you either disavow the
statement so you agree with them nobody
you know statements are made in contact
statements are pre projected somehow
taken out of the context so I know the
country I know the people I know the
Prime Minister that's why I'm very
quietly answering that you are trying to
portray a picture which is not true
again now that I'm quoting statements
that he's made and I'm I'm living in
that country I know the person I know my
people and I know how we behave in
Slovakia is country that respects the
rule and has always respected us so we
should ignore those statements then
let's focus on the facts let's focus on
the substance in other words ignore what
he says look what he does as holders of
the rotating EU presidency you have a
duty to try to hold the Union together
because it appears that so many factions
and countries want different things at
the moment the European Parliament wants
what it calls a refoundation of Europe
France is threatening to stop applying
rules about workers posted from one
state to another
your colleagues the polls and the checks
want president younger the Commission to
stand down what are you trying to do
throw all the cards up in the air at
once no on the kind of time of crisis
and see what happens on the contrary
where's the where's the unity well
that's what we are trying to get that's
what we are trying to forge and that's
why by pulling it apart with a different
idea every day well you cannot prevent
people from having different ideas our
all as the presidency is try to bring
everyone together this is why we have
invited all the leaders to Bratislava
for an informal summit on the 16th of
September to discuss the future of
Europe because everyone is saying that
we need and fresh ideas many different
Europe but all the different president
of the Commission well no one in
Slovakia ever said anything about the
progress of poles and the Czechs your
colleagues and I'm the first grad am I
responsible for just agree with I don't
agree with them I don't agree with you
want to stick with yoga the last thing
we need now at this moment is to point
fingers at each other we respect the
Commission we respect the president of
the Commission we don't think that the
Commission is the problem and we not at
all think that the president of the
Commission is their problem the problem
is that people are losing faith in the
European project and therefore we need
to get together and we need to discuss
what went wrong and what must be done
differently that's what we need but your
split on the migrant issue and you're
also splitting we are split on number of
issues yes well let's look at some of
the like like sanctions on Russia to in
for instance you you have said we need
to define relationships and put them on
realistic ground what does that mean in
terms of your relationship the --use
relationship with Russia what are you
first of all here first of all European
Union is united on sanctions on Russia
because we have our position and the
Reavis has always been unity there are
different comments but when it came to
vote there was always a unity so far you
accused West instead of being
hypocritical who in Russia you did what
I'm saying is I was quoting somebody
else who said that European Union will
never be united in Russia
because the vest is hypocritical and the
East is driven cystic it's not my quote
but I found it interesting you said
without Russia we are unable to solve a
number of local problem obviously
so without Russia we wouldn't have had
Russia is a permanent member of the
United Nations Security Council Russia
is a nuclear power Russia is a global
player no what does that mean so you
accept everything that they do no you
cannot ignore a country that is a
permanent member whose adoring them
you've just tried to yes I'm asking you
about quotes that you've made about
Russia and you seem to be very critical
of the Western stance you know what I'm
saying is that if we refuse to discuss
things then something is wrong with us
and it's not my demand it's a demand
that comes from number of member states
who a number of countries who said we
are going to extend the sanctions but we
want to have a discussion about the
sanctions and there will be a discussion
about the sanctions and it's not because
I've demanded so or my Prime Minister my
president it's the demand that comes
from number of EU Member States and
there is nothing wrong about it why
should we be afraid of discussing things
are we afraid of our own policy
so maybe the outcome of the discussion
will be the confirmation of our position
so what sir what is your position on
this you want sanctions to continue or
not look for me it's important to know
that sanctions are the policy instrument
not the policy in itself not the policy
go
so we've adopted sanctions believing
that they are going to get us somewhere
now it's time to see whether we have we
are where we want it to be or not
whether the sanctions are delivering or
not I'm not going to prejudge the
outcome of the sanctions how are you
going to show your displeasure with the
country that is marched into territory
that doesn't belong to it and as
occupied and annexed it how are you
going to do it without sanctions
Minister I'm a professional diploma for
me sanctions are the last resort and
also the failure of diplomacy I am I
believe in diplomacy has failed as far
as Ukraine and Crimea
as concerned hasn't I don't think it's a
sin and accept that it's a simple
simplification I believe in dialogue I
already believe in critical dialogue
sanctions mean means there is very
little dialogue but some sometimes
sanctions are inevitable and we found
ourselves in that situation and European
Union acted and acted in unity and the
sanctions are still there and they were
extended several times so there is unity
there is a clear position at the same
time if there is a demand for discussing
where we stand with with the sanctions
it's absolutely ok there is no need to
panic about it and this all this the
preparation for just watering down the
sanctions and saying ok Russia you take
whatever territory you want in the
future
and you just go ahead and do that and
we'll just sit there and make a few
noises slap you on the wrist
whatever will be agreed will have to be
agreed by the 28 member states of the
European Union so there is no need to
panic
unless some of them take the you to
court has once again are we the only
country that has it so that means for
some that you for some it's possible and
for some others it's not that's what you
are saying that we are equal and more
equal in the European Union and that's
the philosophy I don't buy so if there
is a if this is a legitimate instrument
that has been used many times in the
past by a number of countries then I
don't really understand why are you
shouting at me for using a chef sorry ok
we're actually keeping a but what I'm
trying to say is that if it is
legitimate if we've never done anything
which is not legitimate so let let's
accept the facts again let's talk about
human rights ok by human rights a
subject dear to your heart I know
because you want to be UN
secretary-general I believe one day
thrown your hat into the ring ten months
ago Slovakia came in for some concerted
criticism from the UN Committee Against
Torture they criticized the length of
pretrial detention which can be as long
as five years in your country reports of
excessive use of force by law
enforcement officials against minors
including Roma and allegations of
ill-treatment that were not investigated
by
independent body do you take these
criticism seriously
of course we do I mean we are subject to
them so why are these things going on in
your country excessive use of force we
have instruments we have the UN Human
Rights Council that reviews the
countries there is a Universal Periodic
Review they come up with with with
certain findings with recommendations we
accept the recommendations that's a very
good way for us to reflect upon upon the
situation and to improve the situation
so what's wrong about it no country is
perfect and if the relevant and
responsible agencies tell us that we
should improve something we will improve
something - being beaten up Roma - being
beaten up by police I mean that's
satisfactory is it well I don't know
whether there have been cases or not I
am the Foreign Minister but if if so
they need to be investigated and and the
legal framework should be reviewed and
we have to make sure that these things
will not be repeated I mean I don't
think that like no country is perfect
and there are excesses there are cases
in every country and this is why we have
this mechanisms this is why we have
these reviews and we have always been
open to these discussions and we will
you we have always amazing so you accept
that there is room for improvement here
well and very very decent and and on
free speech as well there have been a
number of complaints about the retention
of criminal sanctions for defamation
long after international bodies have
called for them to be scrapped the
Council of Europe OSCE UN Special
Rapporteurs on freedom of expression you
have you have the harshest penalties in
the European Union for criminal
defamation up to eight years in prison
why why do you retain these laws
well let's upsurge first of all when it
comes to the freedom of speech that
Slovakia is one of the most free
countries in the world and that's what
the journalists associations are saying
there are absolutely no limits to the
freedom of speech the OSCE has
complained what it is it has nothing to
do it has nothing to do with the freedom
of speech it does because rap has it
pointed at Freedom House pointed out
representatives of the judiciary and
police have on numerous occasions turned
legal means to contain media criticism
this is what you want to contain media
criticism there is a legal framework in
in the country and again if this is a
recommendation it should be looked into
but one thing I know for sure because I
live in Slovakia is that there are no
limits to the freedom of expression and
freedom of speech and and once again
it's one of the most free countries in
the world but you would accept it if you
keep a criminal penalty hanging above
journalists head this is designed to
keep their nose out of politics and out
of the business of the politicians
because the threat of criminal
prosecution is your that threat should
go shouldn't it you are portraying a
picture of a country which is not mine
I mean this is not the situation no no
I'm affecting what international
observers are saying of international
country observers are saying many things
about many countries and if you pick
this take this I take everything
seriously but it does we have to look
into whether this is a real fact or not
if if so then let's talk about it let's
change it that's absolutely no problem
with that
what about arms sales EU guidelines on
arms sales for instance in 2013 the EU
foreign affairs council ruled that
Member States agreed to suspend export
licenses and military equipment to Egypt
you apparently took no notice of this in
2014 you exported military equipment
were three and a half million euros in
the category of vehicles and tanks to
Egypt no way no way this is in the no
official journal of the European Union
no annual reports we don't expect if we
don't explode arms we we certainly exert
some some parts certainly non-lethal and
not not offensive and and we are I mean
if you category of vehicles and tanks
this is this is the UN that no no no
excuse me but my ministry is the
guardian of the respect of international
rules and norms when it comes to the
arms export and I guarantee that we
would never give a green light to the
export of arms to the areas that
prohibited under the UN north of the EU
norms so they got this wrong today
absolutely cause Amnesty International
of that long as well
Amnesty International named you as one
of the countries that is sending arms
military equipment okay
Egypt we are not sending arms to Egypt
believe me I am know something about it
and the Foreign Minister of that country
we everybody else got it wrong not
everybody else got it wrong but I know I
mean there there were some articles in
our media but that article were not
based on truth because what was exported
are some parts but certainly not arms
definitely your categorical assured
absolutely
Yes Minister good to have you on
conflict zone thank you very much indeed
thank you very much
you